credit suisse & señalado de tener
vínculos con delincuentes entre ellos
presuntos violadores de los derechos
humanos y dictadores esto después de una
filtración de datos de las cuentas de
más de 18.000 de sus clientes lafuente
un denunciante que envió sus hallazgos
al periódico alemán süddeutsche zeitung
datos que se transmitieron a varios
medios entre ellos the new york times y
the gardian los hallazgos incluyen
cuentas que se remontan a la década de
1940 y las más recientes son de la del
2010 las 18.000 cuentas acumulaban a más
de 100 mil millones de dólares
algunas de ellas vinculadas a fondos
cuestionables entre los más notables
figura el rey abdullah de jordania quien
depositó 230 millones de francos los
hijos del ex dictador egipcio hosni
mubarak y las cuentas de su difunto jefe
de inteligencia omar suleimán
acusado de torturas también se
identificó al ex presidente de argelia
el difunto abdelaziz buteflika para
muchos la noticia no es una presa suiza
ha luchado por desprenderse de su imagen
de paraíso bancario para los
delincuentes su ley bancaria de
1934 implicaba que los empleados que
revelarán información confidencial de
los clientes podían acabar en la cárcel
aunque las leyes se modificaron
recientemente para combatir el fraude
parte de la legislación todavía
contempla que una persona puede ser
procesada las estrictas leyes han hecho
que muchos empleados hagan la vista
gorda ante el origen delictivo de los
fondos credit suisse ha negado cualquier
infracción y afirmó que el 90% de las
cuentas ya han sido cerradas